Laurie Lachlan and Massimo Gianelli have
agreed to plead guilty in the College
Admission scandal the US Attorney's
Office in the District of Massachusetts
announced on Thursday that Laurie will
plead guilty to one count of conspiracy
to commit wire and mail fraud while
Massimo will plead guilty to one count
of conspiracy to commit wire and mail
fraud and honest services wire and mail
fraud if approved by the court Laurie's
plea deal states that she will serve two
months in prison and two years of
supervised release pay a one hundred and
fifty thousand dollar fine and complete
100 hours of community service meanwhile
under Massimo's proposed plea deal he'll
serve five months in prison and two
years of supervised release pay a two
hundred and fifty thousand dollar fine
and complete 250 hours of community
service the date of Laurie and Massimo's
court appearance has not yet been
announced I want to be supportive of
everything they want to do but I do want
them to have somewhat of a normal you
know finish out of high school college
experience maybe because I didn't have
that I really want that for them the
couple was accused of paying five
hundred thousand dollars in bribes to
get their daughters
Olivia Jade and Isabella Rose admitted
to the University of Southern California
as recruits for the crew team even
though neither of them had ever
participated in the sport I want them to
be happy I'm happy to guide them and get
them up and running they initially
pleaded not guilty to all charges
leveled against them claiming their
payments were donations to the school
not bribes overall I am happy and proud
of my girls and I think that they are
nice people and they are kind people and
I think that's the greatest compliment I
can give them the couple's decision to
plead guilty comes nearly two weeks
after a judge rejected the actresses
request to have the charges against her
dropped at the time a source told ET
that Laurie had quote no plans to back
down from her not guilty plea but the
court's decision did make her nervous I
have a lot of mixed emotions
she never in her life thought she would
ever be in this
position and it's almost like a bad
dream she can't wake up from
[Music]